We humans are soft and squishy, and don’t
like electricity.
Robots are hard and pointy, and they love
it.
So how do we make a robot that’s soft and
squishy like living things, but still gets
power?
Hydrogels of course.
Hard, metal robots are so 20th century.
“Soft-robotics” is hip.
Just like me.
Soft-robotics involves making technology that
is similar to biological material, like we
often find in nature and within ourselves.
We want things kind of like us; soft, durable,
waterproof.
And hydrogels cover all the bases.
But there’s something still holding soft
robots back from taking over the squishy parts
of the world ... Batteries.
Except, electricity and water don’t mix.
Unless you’re one, very specialized animal…
The Electrophorus electricus, commonly known
as the electric eel.
If we can copy the technology that evolution
gave the electric eel, then we can unplug
these organic looking creations, from dry
land with “soft batteries!”
These strange long fish can generate electricity
with an organ containing cells called electrocytes.
Electrocytes by themselves can’t do much
damage, but jammed up all together they can
give a shock of up to 600 volts.
By analyzing the eels, scientists realized
the electrocytes are organized in long stacked
compartments with extra fluid space in between.
They looked at each component in the eel’s
electrocyte and mimicked the same idea into
alternating patterns of saltwater and freshwater
hydrogels.
Saltwater, has salt in it, meaning it’s
an electrolyte.
Here, the red gels are filled with saltwater,
and the blues are filled with freshwater.
At the points where they touch, the negative
ions from within the saltwater flow towards
the empty freshwater.
But that’s not enough to mimic the eel biology.
The yellow and green gels on the seperate
sheet are filled with specialized fluid that
don’t just let the ions flow willy-nilly.
Instead the yellow gels only let negative
ions through, while the green gels only let
positive.
Together, these colorful gels move the ions
in a specific direction, generating a voltage!
Voila!
Electricity from fluids, just like an eel!
By copying this soft squishy battery design,
researchers hope to create soft squishy robots
that can be used as wearable technology, or
in other natural environments, when traditional
batteries could get damaged or be too dangerous.
The thing is, you’ll need a lot of these
little cells to generate enough electricity
to do much with.
Right now researchers can only generate 110
volts from their soft battery, but they’re
working on more…
And I’m ‘eel excited about it.
For more science in your day, please subscribe
to Seeker.
How close are scientists to the perfect battery?
Check out Julian's video here.
And one last fun fact, researchers also used
origami folding techniques to minimize the
space needed for their soft battery.
Pretty cool.
Thanks a lot for watching!